it's your business you want to ignore
all my stuff ignore it I don't care it's
your and if your business collapses you
know what happens to me
nothing prayer is great contemplation is
great but if you don't take action
action action all the rest is wasted
rise and shine it's an espresso time
good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside to you that I want to see
exploded onto the world so let's start
your day off right together grab your
coffee and sip on today's message take
action
over to you simon Sinek you speak to
businesses and companies and leadership
teams and employees and stuff without
mentioning names I don't want to put you
on the spot but have you gone and talked
to a company that's been in trouble and
then spoken to their team and then
checked in on them after you've spoken
to their leadership team and what did
that look like did you notice a
noticeable change did they come to you
and tell you that this has helped our
organization out and our culture is much
improved because of it you mean does my
work I mean sure here's the problem with
my stuff you got to do it and I am not
I'm not anybody's like you know mom or
dad I'm not gonna do it for you and I
have a very less fair approach of it I
once had a one-sided client this is a
bunch of years ago that said what
guarantee do I have that your stuff will
work which my answer was none like I'm
giving you a tool you can it's like a
hammer you can use it broadly or
narrowly you can build a table you can
build a house it's the same tool you can
use it for marketing your music
completely revitalize your entire
culture and even though I'm gonna sell
you the most beautiful hammer I'm not
gonna guarantee the instructional
integrity of the house right it's your
business you want to ignore all my stuff
ignore it I don't care it's your and if
your business collapses you know what
happens to me nothing like I don't mean
to be cold about it like of course I
want the people I work with to do well
but it's not mine it's theirs and I take
no emotional responsibility for the
decisions they make so yes there are
many people that I've had the pleasure
of working with some who worked for
dysfunctional organizations that went on
the hard journey of completely changing
the way they lead and completely
revitalizing their culture and it has
great success it's not because of me
it's because of them right at the same
time there are many
people who came in like what an amazing
speech and did nothing you know thanks
that was great you know and I don't it's
of course it's gonna fail you know so I
I think that we we have too much
especially in the consulting world or
the design world
everybody's so paternalistic about it
ein designers are famous for this right
they get so personally offended when the
client chooses the wrong thing idiots
don't they know we're trying to help
them or who cares like it's their
freakin business right that's what you
find I've had that instead of arguing
with somebody for them to the right
choice which cuz we genuinely want to
help them what I have found is if you
push the accountability to enter because
when we argue we're taking
accountability this is better this will
help you we're taking responsibility
accountability but if we say look we've
been doing this a bunch of years we know
more about design than you do I'm
telling you for every reason that I can
outline for you why this will help you
more but if you don't want to do it
that's fine it's your business do what
you want the minute you switch the
accountability and put it all on them
amazingly they're much more open to your
opinion because now they're responsible
everybody has ideas everybody can close
their eyes and imagine a better world
for themselves imagine a product that
they want to create the service they
want to create the impact that it's
gonna have on their life their community
their customers everybody has ideas but
not everybody takes action on those
ideas and that's the problem I can't
tell you how many people email me and
say hey Evan I've got a great idea that
coca-cola should go and implement or
Nike or McDonald's they're trying to
reach out to these big companies with
this amazing idea that they have I can't
tell how many ideas I have for coca-cola
or Nike or McDonald's the idea alone is
not enough
first of all chances are with these big
companies they've already thought of
your great idea and unless you're coming
in with a patent they're not gonna pay
for the idea of what they pay for is the
execution can you come in and provide
value to them and so the same thing
applies for your own business that idea
that you have in your head might be a
fantastic idea but until you actually
started doing something
about it it's never gonna come true
right you're gonna be lost in the world
of daydreaming where most people are and
that's the dangerous part because I
think it's so easy to get lost in that
world of what could be and we feel good
about it you imagine the type of life
you're gonna have you imagine the
lifestyle and the friends and the impact
that your business is happening and it
just feels good but then you don't want
to do anything about it because it may
not work because it may fail because you
may never ever get there because you may
lose money and resources as time along
the way and so because you've already
solved it in your head then you don't
have to take any action on it the world
belongs to the people who take action
the world belongs to the people who take
that idea that they have and actually do
something about it and that's why it's
hard to be an entrepreneur so many
entrepreneurs that I see and meet
especially the part-time ones you have a
job you're trying to do your thing on
the side you're not consistent you have
one day you take amazing action and the
next day you're not doing anything
you're tired you have your job you have
your family you have your life a lot of
things get in the way and then you don't
actually take any action on your
business where if you spent at least
half an hour every single day every
single day at least half an hour on your
business it starts to build momentum it
may seem like a little tiny step but if
you're taking a little tiny step every
single day soon you look back and
realize I traveled a really big distance
and so I think the biggest thing that
hurts entrepreneurs is not the lack of
ideas we have tons of ideas of what we
want to do is the lack of consistent
action and so if you want to separate
yourself from your friends if you want
to separate yourself from the world that
you're in right now and you want to
build a better life for yourself it's
not just gonna come from the ideas it's
gonna come from you doing something
every single day to move closer to
making that idea a reality now I've got
a special bonus clip for you but before
getting to that my question of the day
for you today is what is the single
biggest action that you are going to
take today for your business leave it
down in the comments below I'm really
curious to find out thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of an espresso and enjoy the bonus
Spray so give me
prayer is great contemplation is great
but if you don't take action action
action all the rest is wasted and what
the kids today I have trouble with they
canal reading a book to take an action
all and I'm not saying you shouldn't
read cuz I've read the classics I've
read Shakespeare and you know all that
stuff but it's not taking action taking
action is pulling the trigger going out
and making something happen and even if
you fail you have to actually show up
every day and into yourself forward
toward these streams and not only show
up every day and once in a while inch
yourself I mean every day you have to
actually take an action that moves you
forward not just research not just
thinking look the power of an intention
is great but without any initiative it's
dead right a dream is great but without
any movement it's dead you have to be
moving towards everyday you can send an
email every day you can make a call
every day you can write something every
day you can create something every day
you can contribute something every day
but it has to be daily otherwise it will
never become actualized and the highest
performers in the world didn't get there
because they were lucky they worked at
it longer than everyone else they had a
better work ethic and something they
necessarily always worked harder they
work smarter because they were doing the
research they were taking the time to
visualize how they would be distinct
different how they would survive the
tough times they really kept at it keep
every single day momentum going and if
you don't do that there's no chance you
can't just wait for inspiration to act
that's the biggest mistake people make
don't wait to be inspired to do the
action you have to do the action first
and then you'll be inspired so what I
would do is I would sit there and draw
up the comic and I would come up with it
but some days I'd come home from school
sit down and go I'm just gonna wait for
the inspiration to hit me oh no wait for
the idea to come fully formed and when I
got a joke then I'll go draw it and I
would sit there for maybe three or four
hours and then go
alright screwed I had to get up in the
day I got to do the process I got to sit
there and just start drawing
I don't even know why or how I'm gonna
get there and then two things would come
together and it'll be oh there's an idea
this is the first panel adjusting but
and then it would come together always
it would not take very long I would
fight that process so much because what
was I doing I was waiting for
inspiration before I acted it's always
the other way around act first then the
inspiration will come draw first then
the inspiration will come just start
shooting then the inspiration okay just
start moving then the inspiration will
come don't wait
so many people wait or tell you they're
gonna write this novel or they're gonna
do this they're gonna make this film
they never do it because they're waiting
for all this stuff to come to them it
comes through doing it yeah the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple so it would be
kind of like a little beacon hey believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details